melissa mccarthy's a cop and Sandra
Bullock is still hot I mean let's watch
this cuz the guy burning parasites off
the wheels in the fifth element was
asking for it so the heat stars Melissa
McCarthy and Sandra Bullock Sandra
Bullock plays this FBI agent she's
really good at her job she's by-the-book
she's one of those people who became an
FBI agent because the paperwork
intrigued her yeah you know the
paperwork that element that keeps people
from being cops no she was like oh that
sounds awesome Melissa McCarthy is the
other side of that coin she's this
Boston cop she's really loud she is not
by the book she's what you think Melissa
McCarthy would be playing if she played
a cop in a movie so no Sandra Bullock
gets transferred to Boston and now they
have to team up to take out you know
drug dealers and crime lord guys it's
exactly what you think it would be in
that aspect it's a buddy cop movie a
good buddy cop movie yeah it is it's
really enjoyable to watch Melissa
McCarthy is awesome first of all I keep
thinking that I'm gonna get sick of her
cuz I feel like what's gonna happen with
Melissa McCarthy is what I kind of see
happening which is what happened to
Johnny Depp Johnny Depp played a role
and he was great in the role and now
it's like oh it's just to have Johnny
Depp play weird eccentric people all the
time I feel like that is happening to
Melissa McCarthy and is going to keep
happening until you know the next decade
she's a really witty fast talking
monologue person let's make her that in
every role the occupation of the role
will change but in the end it's gonna be
Melissa McCarthy in the same role in a
different movie however I'm not sick of
it yet because she's awesome you could
argue that Melissa McCarthy straight-up
makes this movie the one competition
Melissa McCarthy has is the chemistry
between Melissa McCarthy and Sandra
Bullock here in Melissa McCarthy
monologue it's it's not even a person
reading a script because I don't think
it's a script I think 90% of it is
ad-lib but it's Church is what it is she
just keeps going and words keep coming
out you're like oh so this is gospel
that's cool she keeps talking and you're
laughing you're laughing out loud
genuinely
and you have Sandra Bullock and like I
said Sandra Bullock and Melissa McCarthy
work really well together they're pros
but in the end it's still a buddy cop
movie we're about buddy cop movies is
you going to a buddy cop movie going
whatever this is going to be however
they execute it in the end I will have
seen this before a hundred times before
maybe if you think of buddy cop movie
cliches this movie brings the heat and
the heat brings the cliche but it also
brings a couple people who
really carry that premise and make it
feel if not new and refreshing at least
entertaining there's one scene that kind
of feels out of place in the movie I
mean it's really bloody sound like it's
graphic violence bloody it's not like I
was like oh [ __ ] Game of Thrones style
but it was still funny the way they
pulled it off it proved to me you could
make it as messed up as possible and if
you could still pull off the humour
doesn't matter also there are a few
parts in this movie where Melissa
McCarthy I will say she goes overboard
but she does cross the line to
unbelievable it's not on her away it's
the script of the director I'm just
saying you can't pull a gun on someone
who asks you a question who's just a
pedestrian you'd be like yeah now what
alright yeah walk away and I get it cuz
you want to be like I felt like that
before
can't real life be like that or you can
just whip out your piece and be like
shut up and no one thinks twice about it
because it's just kind of a you just
want to because the person's being
obnoxious that being said when something
like that happens in a movie it does
pull me out of it and I go that's just
not realistic
I guess when a cop pulls a gun on a
pedestrian inside a hospital that's when
I draw the line so the heat is fun the
heat is entertaining it's a buddy cop
movie that is full of cliches for sure
Melissa McCarthy kills that Melissa
McCarthy and Sandra Bullock work really
well together this chemistry is like
we're talking it's like end of watch but
comedy version good sometimes it's
unbelievable but it's it's entertaining
it's hilarious and you're gonna laugh
I'm gonna say it's a really strong great
time
no alcohol required I want to say buy it
on blu-ray this is why I hate writing so
what's the rating so one sentence
summary of an entire video that you just
already watched porn is it's funny they
work well together it's cliche but
you'll have a good time suppose C or C
your favorite buddy cop comedy of all
time whatever it may be comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]